how likely is it that jimmy garoppolo
will be on a different team in week one
scale of one to ten with obviously ten
meaning the most likely he'll be on a
new team
well i'm not going to be as convinced as
you are i don't think i'm only a six on
this and simply because i don't know
that the 49ers are going to get what
they want to get from jimmy g they can
afford to keep him on the team i think
he might end up being the ryan
fitzpatrick for the 49ers in other words
he's going to start the season at
quarterback and then by
the bye week he's gone and the new guy
comes in and is ready to take the reigns
and jimmy g's out the door after the
season in trade the problem they face in
trying to trade him is teams are mostly
set at quarterback right now now there's
still some looking we know but at what
point are they going to trade him if
they don't do it by the draft and i
don't think they will because i don't
think they'll get the offer they like
that i think he's going to end up being
on the team mike uh in this season and
whether he plays or not i guess that's
the big question they'll have to
determine whether that rookie is ready
to come in and start right away so i'm
probably not as convinced as you are
that that he's going to be gone before
the season starts
i'm in a nine and here's why i'm at a
nine i believe they have a plan they
have a float chart they didn't go into
this trade without knowing that they're
gonna have to do something with jimmy g
the reason they're making the trade for
a new quarterback is because garoppolo
is not the future even though he's still
fairly young he could play for a lot
longer he came into the league 14 years
after tom brady for crying out loud but
they know he's not the guy because they
can't trust him to stay healthy he's
been injured too often 23 games missed
in three years
the flow chart though i think gets
complicated very quickly it's almost as
complicated as the red yarn behind
conspiracy mike
a photo that we've used pretty much
every day this week and it's probably
just a matter of time before it comes up
again but you'd like to maybe
maybe trade him before the draft or
during the draft maybe you've sprinkled
enough intrigue out there to get someone
who doesn't get the quarterback that
they're hoping to get in round one
to make a move for jimmy garoppolo it's
a trade that would entail i believe
garoppolo taking less than he's due to
make that's the one thing i believe
20 on a scale of 1 to 10 he's not making
25 million this year
the question is will that reduction come
as part of a trade to a new team
or
will it be a situation where the 49ers
find themselves with garoppolo on the
roster the middle of august they're
convinced that their rookie is ready to
go
they're concerned about the possibility
of a wait for it schism in the locker
room between the garoppolo crowd and the
rookie third all pick crowd so they go
to garoppolo and they say we can't pay
you 25 million this year we just can't
we can't we've paid you a ton of money
over the past several years thank you it
took a little while but but better never
than late the
but they go to garoppolo the middle
august late august and say
we want you to take 15. if you don't
take 15 or 13 or whatever they think is
the right number we're going to cut you
and and that's the point where
he's out of options shireen because no
one else is going to sign him and give
him that kind of money in late august
and we've seen that happen time and
again with the nfl and players who don't
have guaranteed contracts there's a
right time to squeeze them
and i i i think that he's a guy
that if all else fails could get dumped
by the 49ers if he refuses
to take less money he may ultimately
realize it's better to take 15 13 12
whatever than become a free agent a week
before the start of the season with
everyone set on their death chart and
there's the other possibility the teddy
bridgewater angle
that
somebody's going to get injured
and you know i i don't want to jinx
anyone but if a quarterback gets injured
in august all of a sudden you have a
trade market for a guy for which there
wasn't a trade market just like the
eagles five years ago got a one and a
four for sam bradford and were able to
move directly and immediately to carson
wentz
yeah that absolutely could happen mike
and that's probably the the best case
scenario for the 49ers and obviously the
worst case scenario for whoever has to
trade for him i think it's going to say
a lot about jimmy garoppolo if he
doesn't end up back in new england
because we know the patriots are looking
for that franchise guy
yes they have cam newton but i'm not
sure they're convinced that cam newton
is the guy otherwise they give him a
long-term contract right so
i think that you know they're still
looking for that guy and jimmy was
destined to be that guy we thought and
then they traded him to the 49ers and he
wasn't that guy and now they have a
chance probably to get him back and if
they don't get him back to me that's
that speaks a little bit about what the
patriots think of of jimmy garoppolo
mike
and remember the comments earlier this
week jermaine wiggins former nfl tight
end was with the patriots for their
first super bowl run on weei said that
some of the guys on that team
look at jimmy g sideways and wonder can
they trust him can he stay healthy will
he be able to show up and play that's
the indictment that's why the 49ers get
rid of him now it doesn't help that he
freaked out kyle shanahan in the 2019
playoffs to the point that shanahan made
him into bob greasy with eight passes
thrown in the entire nfc championship
win over the green bay packers but it's
not about his play it's not about his
ability to run the offense it's about
his inability to play that's why they're
moving on and i if
i
i don't think any fan base should want
him to be the guy unless you feel pretty
damn good about who the backup is and
you're right if the patriots aren't at
the front of the line to try to acquire
garoppolo at a reduced contract like
they did with trent brown this year when
the raiders were done with him and we're
going to cut him eventually patriots
swoop in do a low draft pick deal pay
him less let him become a free agent
next year i i if that doesn't happen
with garoppolo then maybe that tells us
everything we need to know about how
other teams should view him speaking of
the 49ers and that move up to number
three
scale of one to ten how locked into mac
jones are the 49ers
uh given that they now hold that third
pick after trevor lawrence and
presumably zach wilson go off the board
i'm gonna go with an eight on this one
mike and i'm gonna leave it open-ended
because we don't know for certain who
the teams before them are gonna pick
like we think jacksonville is gonna take
trevor lawrence and we know
uh what urban meyer told peter king that
it was trending that way whatever
whatever i mean we expect that to happen
and we expect the jets
right to take zach wilson but we don't
know that for sure so i think there's at
least a little bit of uncertainty on the
49ers part of okay if somebody happens
to take mac jones then we we are ready
to take zach wilson or trevor lawrence
or whoever that might be so that's
probably the only reason i'm leaving it
open i know i've seen a couple of 49ers
writers throw out the name trey lance
and they they think that the 49ers are
going that direction but i still think
all the signs seem to point to mack
jones as the next quarterback of the
49ers
trevor lawrence is going to be the first
pick in the draft i don't think there's
any if about it i think urban meyer is
just trying to preserve a little sliver
of mystery barring some sort of an
unexpected event some sort of a of a
barber chair mishap when he gets his
haircut before the draft and
i i'm officially old when i say trevor
lawrence
get a haircut but barring something like
that he's going to be the first overall
pick and it's pointing to wilson at two
i think this trey lance stuff that's
being planted by the 49ers
is
part of a jedi mind trick they know what
they're hearing about the falcons being
interested in lance and we know what the
49ers did four years ago when the bears
traded up one spot in the top five maybe
they do a flip-flop three and four if
they are convinced the falcons are going
to take trey lance they slide to four
they still get mac jones and they get
back some of what they gave up to move
from 12 to three i really do think that
the lance angle is a smoke screen
and maybe they can get the falcons if
they truly believe the falcons are
looking at lance to go up to number
three and make that move and then it
would be something that the falcons went
up the number three and took mack jones
but then the 49ers could take trey lance
and say that's the guy we were going to
take all along anyway but there's some
risk there i think it's nine i think
it's jones
uh
barring something unexpected unforeseen
i believe sims even though sims doesn't
know what shanahan is thinking now sims
has known shanahan long enough to have
an understanding of the way he thinks
and the way he would think in this
situation and this is the ultimate
litmus test for whether or not sims
really does know shanahan because if
it's not mac jones i'm never listening
to anything that sims ever has to say
again about what kyle shanahan may or
may not want because his barometer
has been completely and totally busted
by this mac jones prediction all right
let's move on to justin fields who going
into the season
it was trevor lawrence justin fields
trevor lawrence justin fields and justin
fields kicked the crap out of trevor
lawrence's team in the bcs semifinal
playoff i can never get that order of
words exactly right regardless justin
fields was looking good but now he's
fading so scale of one to ten
how much do you buy into this narrative
that justin fields is being underrated
and overlooked given the idea that there
is a sense out there that
he's maybe fifth
out of the five top quarterbacks
i'm a one on this mike because i think
this is all media driven and i would say
stop the drama on this because we don't
know how all 32 teams are thinking
nobody does there's no media person out
there who knows what all 32 teams are
thinking and where they have justin
fields ranked on their big board right
the 32 teams don't know where the 32
teams have justin fields on their board
somebody has him above five i i just i
feel like he's going to be
where he should go and wherever that is
and i do think it's going to be in the
top ten but wherever that is
who cares who cares you're still going
to be a first-round draft pick patrick
mahomes wasn't the first quarterback
drafted in his draft class he should
have been but he wasn't justin herbert
last year wasn't the first quarterback
drafted in his draft class probably
should have been but he wasn't so it
doesn't matter how dare you
go how
how dare you speak ill of joe burrow i
agree with you sorry go ahead
but you know it doesn't make any
difference mike where you drafted you
come in you play you prove yourself
a lot of people think justin field's
going to be a really good quarterback in
this league and some team is going to
commit to him and he's going to get his
opportunity
look i think there's going to be panic
buying when it comes to drafting
quarterbacks we talked earlier in the
week either on the morning show the
afternoon show maybe both i can't
remember i had my covet vaccine
yesterday that's my excuse for anything
that i screw up
for the next two weeks until it fully
kicks in i'm going to use that as a
blank check regardless the idea that
because quarterbacks number one are so
much better coming into the league i
think they're doing a better job the
teams are of scouting them and also
adapting to their skills and avoiding
their weaknesses when you get a guy who
is the guy you've got your position
solved for at least 10 maybe 15 years
maybe you get lucky and you can stretch
it all the way to 20 given the way these
guys are playing given the way they're
obsessed with fitness and diet and doing
everything they can to be cyborgs
24 7 52 weeks out of the year
that's the most important position it
already was it's even more important and
where are you going to get that great
quarterback you're going to get him at
the top of the draft and if you swing
and miss you're going to be right back
there in a few years to try it again and
you keep trying until you get him so i
think that the idea that fields is being
overlooked is a little overblown and
i don't want to go too far down this
rabbit hole but there was an analyst on
another network who stepped in something
brown and smelly this week and has spent
some time scraping off of his shoe all
because he fell victim
to the time-honored tradition
of teams who secretly love a guy
spreading negative stuff
in the hopes that he falls and
eventually in the shoe scraping process
said analyst finally acknowledged that
well if you would have been thinking
about that
before you ever said anything about the
guy before you pass along any of the
negative stuff that gets said every year
about every prospect because there's
teams out there that want him to fall
and they want people in the media to
spread the bs that's why i never listen
to the anonymous opinions of scouts and
i never listen to anyone in the league
who tells me or tries to tell me i don't
like this guy because of this i don't
like this guy because of that i've done
this long enough to know that they want
to find a way to get that guy to slide
so they can get him shireen and i think
some of that's been going on
particularly with justin fields
it happens every year mike just go back
and look in the history and it uh
more times than not it's with the
quarterbacks but we hear it over and
over and over again but wait mike you
didn't give us one to ten which so
what's your scale are you a one with me
on this
yeah like i always know when matt casey
is instigating okay sharing you can't
sell it you can't sell it i know it's
wow
maybe maybe she's maybe she's she's
learned the patterns
i'll say that that it is
what did you say it was a one
i said a one you say it was a one i'll
say it two then just because i don't
want to say it was a one since you said
it was a one but it's low it's low i i
think that there's a lot of good there
there's a lot of good there um and i
know
hey
i know
from doing this for 20 years now
that scouts do get enamored with what a
guy does on a big stage and what he did
against clemson that night was
spectacular you can't just wipe that
away just because time has passed and
there's going to be somebody out there
that i mean we wouldn't have guessed a
week ago that the 49ers had fallen in
love with mac jones or whoever they're
going to take at three they've quietly
and secretly fallen in love with someone
you got five top quarterbacks in this
draft
chances are there are one or more teams
that believe that each of those guys is
the guy for them so i think that it is a
low possibility and that leads into our
next question how likely is it
that five quarterbacks will get drafted
in the top ten the five being trevor
lawrence zach wilson mack jones trey
lance justin fields maybe not in that
order
i'm gonna go with the five i do think
it's a possibility i also think it's a
possibility that one of those guys could
follow the top ten but none of them are
gonna have to wait that long there's no
question about that they're gonna be in
the top half of this draft there's gonna
be that run on quarterbacks as you said
they always go higher than we think they
could go and i don't think it's out of
the question either that calaman goes
late in the first round like lamar
jackson did a couple years ago three
years ago i think that definitely could
happen that we could have six
quarterbacks go in the first round of
this draft because a team could panic
and say well we're not going to get the
guy we really wanted and we really
wanted a quarterback out of this draft
so
they're going to go quickly mike and
they're not going to wait long to hear
their names called top half of the draft
for sure top ten i'm not quite willing
to go quite that far there have to be
some trades for that to happen when you
look at the teams that aren't going to
draft a quarterback there
but there's already been one i i'd say
between one the the three teams that we
know i mean we're already at three the
question is
will there be two taken in the next
seven picks when you consider that three
are coming off the board right out of
the gates and you've got the falcons
who may or may not be locked into trey
lance you've got the panthers who
clearly are looking for a franchise
quarterback and you got the broncos who
are looking for anyone other than drew
locke that's three more teams right
there
after the first three teams take
quarterbacks i'm gonna say it's an eight
eight and a half that we're gonna have
five taken in the top ten i'm holding
out hope for five taken in the top five
if if we're gonna really go all in with
this ultimate reality show that is the
nfl draft that begins in 27 days yes
let's do it let's go five for five let's
show how important the quarterback
position is and let's have that run on
them right out of the gates all right
next question before we can pose it it
requires some sound from earlier this
week patriots owner robert kraft talking
about the struggles that his team has
had when it comes to finding talented
players in the draft
really the teams
who draft well are the ones who will be
consistently good i don't feel we've
done the greatest job
the last few years and i really hope
and i believe i've seen a different
approach
this year and you know in the end it all
comes out to
what happens on the field and how well
people execute and you really don't know
a draft
how good a draft is for at least two
years we have a situation
where we have you know at this point in
time
um we're trying to do what the best
thing for us is you know i think in
fairness to cam
i'm not sure
he had the proper weapons around him
last year and then he got
covered and there were a lot of things
that happened and
i don't know that jared has
ever really gotten a fair shot so
we we have to wait and see what happens
and
this isn't something where you get
algebraic formulas
think of all the
personnel wizard who passed for six
rounds on tom brady
and so one way or another we have to get
that position solidified
okay so how much of robert kraft's very
candid comments
regarding the patriots roster and their
difficulties in drafting are a shot at
coach bill belichick scale of one to ten
shireen
well i i think we need some
clarification here an intentional shot
or just the the fact that bill belichick
drafted those players and didn't draft
the right players
in other words was it an intentional
shot at bill belichick or just him
speaking reality but i don't think he
intended it to be that
intentional shot at bill belichick but
facts are facts so
i i guess i'm around it as six on this
um but but facts are facts and the
patriots haven't drafted well they
haven't developed that talent as you
keep pointing out and that's just
something that leads them to where they
are today because they don't have the
franchise quarterback they've had to go
out and spend big and free agency tons
of money and free agency to try to
improve that roster because the drafts
haven't worked out and they've traded
far too much
sit where you are and take the best
player available and they just haven't
done that because bill belichick thinks
he can outwit other people and it hasn't
worked out for them in these recent
drafts mike
you came dangerously close to the bruce
aryans i'm not ripping anybody i'm just
being honest excuse for bob kraft
exactly it is a shot it's clearly a shot
and as we've discussed it's not just
drafting it's drafting and developing
because it's not like they're making
these ridiculous pics that people are
saying who the hell is that guy he
wasn't even on anyone's board they're
drafting nfl caliber talent they're not
developing that nfl caliber talent
regardless of whether you've drafted a
guy in round three that you should have
drafted in around six he's still a
draftable player and you're not
developing him i think that's part of it
but i think the shot here when i heard
it and listened to it and he said that
he's seen some things this year that
makes him think the draft this year is
going to be better than it's been in
recent years i think it's a shot at
casario nick casario now the gm of the
houston texans and you know we've seen
the patriots keep the people they want
to keep and when they wanted to keep
casario they kept casario all of a
sudden casario's the gm of the patriots
or the patriots the texans excuse me
i think the patriots had gotten to the
point where they were ready to move on
from casario and if they weren't he'd
still be there i think it was more of a
shot at him than belichick so i'm gonna
say it's a four of a shot at belichick
and i think the people in the building
understand where the problems were in
recent years and now they're trying to
rectify those issues and i love the
candor from bob craft and you know
people act like it's something new it's
not new it's just shirini hasn't had to
do it since 2000. when you're great for
20 years you never have to be honest
about anything that would be negative
about the people running your football
team
yeah that's exactly right mike hasn't
had had to fire a head coach right
hasn't had to find that franchise
quarterback in a really long time so
they've been smooth sailing for two
decades and until tom brady left that's
the that's the way it was
we talked earlier about the three
categories of teams teams with franchise
quarterbacks teams desperately looking
for franchise quarterbacks and teams
that have a guy that may or may not
become one patriots like washington
category number two
here's robert kraft talking about the
departure of tom brady from new england
a year after he exited for tampa and won
a championship
i
would have loved for him to have retired
as a patriot everybody knew that but in
life things just happen in a way that
you have to balance a lot of things
after 20 years i thought he was entitled
to
make a decision that was
what he thought was best for him and
where he was
and
you know we gave him the ability to do
that you know it's like marriages
sometimes
no one knows on the outside everything
going on and you try to balance a lot
and it is what it is look we could have
contract-wise kept him
in our camp but it's just
it's not the right thing and naturally
we
we want to win but who knows what would
have happened if he stayed here look
what happened at the end of
his last season here
so the question attached to that sound
bite shireen how much do you believe
robert kraft regrets not keeping tom
brady in 2020 and potentially beyond
scale of one to ten
oh the lies we tell ourselves he's
looking back at tom brady's last year
throwing the pick six at the end of the
titans game and them losing but he knows
in his heart of hearts they might have
won another super bowl if they had kept
tom brady i'm a 10 on this i think
there's huge regret on his part not
necessarily bill belichick's part but on
robert kraft's part huge regret after
seeing the buccaneers win the super bowl
that tom brady wasn't his quarterback
and doing that for the new england
patriots and doing it for the tampa bay
buccaneers instead because
you know his legacy is always going to
be in new england we understand that but
this has just added another layer to tom
brady that maybe he didn't need the
patriots to do what he did
see i'm gonna say it's a three and i'm
only saying it's three instead of one
because the fact that brady won a super
bowl with the buccaneers we'll bump it
up a little higher i just don't think
that kraft is the kind of guy who's
going to regret moves that are made as a
result of strategic decision-making
understanding of all the risks a
realization of the way that things may
go and could go and will go
it was time for the patriots and tom
brady to go their separate ways what the
patriots did last year is the exact
opposite of what the steelers did with
ben roethlisberger this year the
steelers should have ripped off the
band-aid this year with ben
roethlisberger and i firmly believe by
the time we get to november december one
or both sides will regret that they
didn't the patriots decided and i
disagree with you sharing i don't think
they win a super bowl last year with tom
brady because the rest of the team
wasn't good enough that's the thing if
the team is otherwise good enough then
we keep tom around and try to win one
more the team's not good enough for a 43
year old quarterback to come in and make
the difference the way made the
difference in tampa bay so let's just do
it now let's let him move on now and
when he talks about the concept of
marriages and to the outside it's viewed
one way there was dysfunction between
brady and belichick brady had enough of
belichick and
look
belichick is the kind of guy that i
don't know where
the shelf life of dealing with belichick
ends but it's somewhere between two
years and 20 years and brady was well
past his lifetime supply of dealing with
bill belichick and i think that was a
big part of it so even if they wanted
brady
it was clear that brady was ready to
move on and i think brady recognized
that the team around him wasn't nearly
good enough to get him that seventh
super bowl championship that he wanted
so badly
yeah no question about that i do agree
with you on that part mike but i think
there's a difference between brady's
relationship with belichick and brady's
relationship with robert kraft
completely different relationships i
think craft and brady have a tight
relationship and i think kraft really
wanted tom brady to finish his career
with the new england patriots and it
didn't happen right he's gone on to win
a super bowl with the buccaneers you're
right they probably wouldn't have done
it in new england with the team they had
but who's to say that tom brady couldn't
have recruited all those guys in new
england now maybe bill belichick says
we're not recruiting all these guys in
new england but maybe robert kraft steps
in and say hey this is what tom brady
wants give him one more chance to win a
ring so maybe they end up with some of
those guys that tampa bay got to come uh
to them this year but
the based on what they had on the field
last year yeah they weren't going to win
a super bowl with whoever they had it
quarterback mike no question about that
but i do think they wanted him to retire
as a patriot
gronk wasn't coming back to new england
he got the hell out of there because he
reached his lifetime limit of bill
belichick and there's no way antonio
brown was coming back to new england so
they would have had a hard time getting
even to the playoffs with tom brady last
year and uh if if anything what happened
last year with braden
for the patriots this year is he worth
the yeah they went seven and nine how
many more wins did they get with tom
brady
uh maybe they go nine and seven
and maybe they just maybe they barely
get in as as the seventh seed and get
and lose well they would have had to win
they would have had to win ten to get
then they would have gotten in nine and
seven and they wouldn't have gotten in
um
all right last one and this one is only
for you because i don't live in texas
it's not my place to comment on any of
the political decisions or social
decisions made by the citizenry of the
lone star state so you're all alone on
this one
how
smart
one or stupid 10
is your home state of texas for allowing
full capacity at the texas rangers games
beginning whenever they begin
well i think it's stupid so i'm going to
go with 10 but having said all that
there are tickets available because the
texas rangers are not very good
a lot of people don't want to go sit in
a full crowd so this game is not sold
out we'll see how many people actually
show up to this game they gave up they
scored five runs in the first yesterday
gave up five runs in the first and lost
14-10 gave up two touchdowns so mike
nolan might have gone for the cowboys to
the rangers
that's great amy trask chiming in with
the lucille ball she is excellent with
the lucille ball gifts and what makes
those even better is 85 percent of the
people who use twitter have no idea who
lucille ball
is but but but you're right of all teams
to go full capacity it's a team that
can't sell out anyway
great seats still available at the texas
rangers home stadium
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports